al-jazeera's chance transfer joins us
now live from our Chocula on the
turkey-syria border bring us up to speed
Charles what's the latest the latest
Adrian is all these questions as to
whether the Turkish military has taken
full control of the town of Russell Ann
which is to the east of here as was
claimed yesterday by the Turkish Defense
Ministry I mean that was initially
disputed and has been disputed for hours
now by the SDF certainly according to
the Syrian Observatory for Human Rights
they're saying that the SDF forces have
retaken control of what they describe is
almost all the city so ongoing
developments there we know that there
were fierce clashes in the city and
around the city or reports of over night
with respect to where I am here which is
on the Turkish side of border opposite
the town of tal Abyad where we've seen
some very heavy bombardment artillery
bombardment over the last few days
that's just started again in the last
hour or so according to the Syrian
fighters that are participating in this
offensive with the Turks they're saying
that they control around 13 different
villages around tell our Br there have
been rumors of some sort of ground
offensive beginning and very difficult
to say whether that has started yet we
heard from the SDF last night again
calling in a press conference story
yesterday again calling for some sort of
no-fly zone to be to be set up across
northern Syria and there are increasing
reports that the SDF may well be looking
to reaching out to Russia and the Syrian
regime to try and work some sort of deal
out because of the kind of pressure that
they're under by the Turks I mean we
can't come in dependent ly confirm those
lines but it certainly shows you the
kind of pressure that the SDF could well
be under and the kind of allegiances
that could well be shifting as this
offensive goes forward
jobs there are videos beginning to
emerge online that are alleged to show
the abuse an execution of both civilian
and YPG Syrian Kurds what more do we
know about that
that's right yeah there have been videos
released of allegedly showing these
Turkish back Syrian fighters executing a
man on the side of a road there was also
been a video released allegedly showing
the the body of a woman who's a very
prominent Kurdish political activist
described by the Kurds as being a
politician and the leader of a party
after certainly according to the Syrian
Observatory from human rights alleging
that she and nine other civilians was
were executed on the side of a road in
northern Syria yesterday interestingly
there has been a statement by the
opposition Syrian army these are the as
I say the men the fighters that are
being supported by the Turks they are
saying that they are going to launch an
investigation into these allegations and
they are calling on their commanders in
the field to make sure that no abuses
take place no violations at take place
they are at this stage rejecting that
that they are responsible for them but
it's not an outright rejection interest
in either language is quite clever so
they are condemning what they see in the
videos and they are calling for an
investigation into exactly what may or
may not would happen but the propaganda
war here and I think we should be
careful between the Turks and the Kurds
is increasing as we go forward day in
day out
al Jazeera's Charles Stratford life
there on the turkey-syria border Charles
many thanks